we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p now this voicemail is
part of a bigger thing that happened
over the weekend there was this trump
rally in anchorage alaska i covered the
rally we had a nice audience so 15 16
000 live viewers on a random saturday
night nice audience
lots of people who don't like me and who
don't like leftism
stumbled across my live stream
and they felt furious in an entitled way
where they they spent the last two days
writing to me saying
why are you interrupting the great
president trump with your commentary one
guy even said i should leave the country
or something uh and here's another
caller who really didn't like the fact
that i covered the trump rally the way i
wanted to cover it as if you couldn't
just find another stream
you know it's painful to watch your show
because i'm trying to watch the trump
rally and all your tortoise talking over
it right make a snide comments why don't
you shut the [ __ ] up and let me let us
listen
okay
watch it somewhere else
watch it somewhere else you don't have
to listen to me you don't have to watch
my stream i'm doing my commentary and
the level of entitlement from people
saying i shouldn't be speaking over the
president just let him tell his lies
unchallenged
i'll do it the way i want to do it
and even by the way maybe not
surprisingly
xenophobic
and anti-semitic responses to the fact
that i had the audacity to speak over
the great orange anointed one
uh give me a break guys i'll do the show
the way i want to do the show you can
watch somewhere else if you don't like
it we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today joe biden says he is
considering
uh declaring a health emergency over
abortion access and we're going to talk
about what that means and what might be
the result of doing that
a pregnant woman in texas
was pulled over in the carpool lane and
she made the argument and i believe it's
a good argument listen uh
based on the law
i have a person in my belly right now
and so therefore i should be able to use
the carpool lane and of course this is
the kind of silliest example of the
absurdity of the right-wing person heard
arguments i've said before
doesn't if it's a person if the fetus is
a person they should have citizenship
if the fetus is a person
it should be entitled to child support
etc and they don't want to do any of
that but here's another just glaring
example of this absurdity why can't you
be in the carpool lane if that's a
person
uh in the womb so we will talk about
that and then number three there is a
new law in arizona seeking to limit the
recording of interactions with police
we're going to talk about the first
amendment legal community saying you
can't do that that's actually you know
for all the times that the right loves
to say that what about my first
amendment
what about my free speech they don't
know what the hell they're talking about
we have an actual first amendment issue
here which we will discuss on the bonus
show sign up at joinpackman.com
get instant access to the bonus show and
of course you can use the coupon code
big voting 22 to get yourselves a
discount we're here all week
unless anything changes and look forward
to seeing you tomorrow or on the bonus
show in mere minutes